I'm going to talk about a project that
I've been involved with for the last
there we go two years already which is
met a vid so that the image that goes
did behind the the word met amid there
is taken by a government employee every
almost every day almost every weekday
anyway Congress meets in Washington and
we have these remote controlled cameras
that government employees operate on our
behalf and this is open content and this
is kind of the story of that content so
what is benefit it's an open access
archive a video and associated metadata
from US House and Senate floor
proceedings it's entirely open sores and
patent free from the ground up and it's
open content so it's public domain
mostly and we'll get into that so it
came out of the UC Santa Cruz digital
arts a new media program where both i
and my collaborator michael dale were
MFA students and it it actually started
with some research that we were both
doing some research on archives I was
looking at how public domain content can
sometimes fall into this whole of
enclosure where you know even though
we're supposed to have access to it we
can't always actually even get at it e
to use it to reuse it and so I thought
I'd be able to put that down and makes a
mark and what I wanted to do it was
2,000 for it was the time of the
elections I wanted to get some video
footage of debates the presidential
debates and some congressional debate
cut out everything but the pronouns
right pronouns are these kind of
interesting semiotic devices when a
politician uses them it's even more
interesting because they claim to
represent us right so when they say i we
i thought i could just cut them all down
to that it would be kind of a cute
little project and then i started
looking for footage
when I ended up with it's kind of small
but I end up with the shopping cart from
c-span org which is really like the path
of least resistance to congressional
footage right and so I ended up with two
coffee mugs for like six bucks a pop and
some footage and it came out to
seventeen hundred dollars minus five
bucks and so in kind of like looking at
best practices this is maybe what
inspired this isn't bad practices and so
at first I was kind of surprised and and
I went in and I looked there was some
talk of like what policies educational
use policies might look like in here
c-span's and so they have a policy that
educators can use any c-span programming
and they have a lot of their own
proprietary programming that they do
like book TV Washington journal and they
exempt the public domain material that
they carry that's in this license so
it's clear okay well it is public domain
but it's thirty to sixty dollars an hour
so when we started looking at this
process here's how things were so they
were taking the government feeds to go
to the press gallery they were
rebroadcasting them they put them on the
web for two weeks and 160 120 pixels
that postage stamp that somebody was
talking about earlier in real video
after that point it was thirty to sixty
dollars per hour from their archive and
they would make you sign licensing
agreements hearings not public domain
copyright c span lido hearing enters
public domain in 2101 at least their
coverage of it on web for a very period
same size lots of money wait what's that
license about okay well you need a
license to do public performances
documentaries films television this is
in addition to the seventeen hundred
dollars that so this is like way beyond
what an art student could ever dream do
it for
and then here's all the things that they
just absolutely don't permit duplication
posting on the internet airing on public
access fundraising use so we have some
enclosure take taking place in a few
different levels real video how many of
you have ever tried to download a real
video file and use it for something how
did that go yeah okay I don't what right
but I mean it was pretty much designed
to make that really difficult so they
have a physical archive it used to be
tied to Purdue University it's not
anymore actually and access is pretty
limited and then they have these license
agreements that further limit what you
can do with this footage of what the
people who represent us do and so Mike
and I started talking about well how
could we reimagine this what you know
how can we can test this and what's
possible with current and emerging
technology and so kind of looking at the
architecture of what they had done as a
recipe of maybe we should try doing the
opposite well it's open content it
should be easy to save it should be easy
to reuse and repurpose if somebody wants
you know somebody looking at a clip of
their representative they should be able
to keep it on their hard drive forever
you know it's their employee open
technology which there's so much to
learn from the open source community in
terms of interoperability and being able
to share with each other so we started
looking at all of these different
projects that were out there some of
them that we're already working together
and some not so much some of those icons
might look familiar and we started
tinkering with them seeing what would
fit together what wouldn't I know it's a
little small but here's the three dollar
cable splitter that we got at Radio
Shack so we have the cable feed that we
split so we can get c-span one and two
for the house and the Senate here are
the two fifty dollar TV capture cards
that bring you mpeg-2 here's the Linux
box that we built and here's some free
software and some other sources of
metadata and a bunch of hard drives so
we started archiving video but not just
video along with this cable signal of
video you also get closed caption text
which we thought could be interesting to
use down the line and we also had these
names of it c-span was writing on the
screen of who's talking and so we
started thinking well wouldn't it be
cool if we got some open source OCR
software and actually read that off so
we know who was talking it was kind of a
joke but like two weeks later we'd
figured we'd done it so i don't know
i'll show the project now so we've been
archiving Senate and House floor
proceedings since last January in a
video format called OGG Theora which
most of you probably never heard of but
it's completely patent free it was
developed by on to the people that
develop what is now flash video what
they actually gave their patent to all
of humanity to use for whatever they
wanted for this older technology that
they developed so here is just the
directory with all of the auxiliary
gigabytes some days go eight hours
sometimes they show up you get a pledge
of allegiance and an opening prayer and
they go home
really and you know that's kind of the
thing like if you buy seventeen hundred
dollars worth of tape shoes from c-span
you get these long it's like sometimes
eight hours eight-hour days you don't
really know when the thing you really
want to look at is so having this video
is linear video as those of you have
tried to watch this man probably know
it's really unwatchable and so that was
a problem for this kind of interesting
project that we were trying to build
like whoa okay now we've got these
really long video files that are
unwatchable great you know you they're
bigger than postage stamps they look ok
but well how do we make that usable so
that's where the closed caption data
became useful because that's time to
text when you have time text you can use
it as a search index so if you search
for something like a chess sketch and
it's actually looking for edge and
sketch but here all of these clips of
byron Dorgan and he's done this like on
six different days
give them a day off for months you can
do that can do that here and so that
that's why these companies are moving
their jobs good okay this is our java
player being kind of funky and Mac
Firefox so since not all browsers are
alike in their ability to play Java you
can actually take these links and copy
them directly into VLC which will play
them really smoothly in the next version
of Firefox and opera there will be
native the aura support which is going
to make things a lot better for us and
there's also actually a VLC Mozilla
add-on that plays it more smoothly you
can also actually download these streams
directly to your hard drive so this is
about 35 seconds of him talking about it
to sketch you have this long URL here
that shows what day it is is from 2006
one hour 24 minutes and 49 seconds in
and 35 seconds beyond that and you can
actually change these and select a
limited portion of the video it will
grow just that portion and rewrite the
keyframes for you so you don't need to
download eight hours to get a particular
portion that you're looking for so okay
that was closed caption text that was
kind of having that layer of metadata
kind of enabled some interesting kinds
of searches we also had the names that
were able to read off the screen and
that made us really create one you know
who's talking there's all this data
about who they are right and so I'm
gonna I guess this is still coming in
this is kind of an experimental overlay
mode which kind of demonstrates the
advanced searches you can search by
person you can search by what they said
and you can actually bound it with date
ranges all of these searches are also
available as an RSS feed so you can
subscribe to it in democracy player keep
an eye on particular issue as said by a
particular person for instance
but so when you have this information
about who's talking you can also go out
and find information about them and so
what this is going to do in a minute
here is it actually goes out and gets
campaign finance data about who's
talking in real time based on the OCR
name data that we have and so it'll be
saxby chambliss sorry the audio doesn't
work on this but sacra Chambliss he's
talking about the impact of border
security on agribusiness and we'll see
how that goes I might actually have to
let this load and move on while it does
that I'll show it to you later since
we're tight on time so core components
OGG Theora it's basically a streaming
codec but we're also archiving in it
300k per second in 900k per second the
high quality streams are a little bit
less funky than stuff we've seen on The
Daily Show which is kind of a threshold
for us it will have native support in
Firefox and opera probably November a
node X is open source technology that
lets you grab these small portions of a
video without having to download the
entire thing which when you're dealing
with 9 our video files is pretty
important we're working on moving all of
our closed caption text into mediawiki
so people can use that to correct the
mistakes that tend to occur to annotate
and to create links we've got many
hundreds hours of video you can play it
in the browser external applications RSS
it's easy to embed for bloggers like on
our blog
we can take care and funding for rat
escalation I want
see running well he reads this this
great version of Humpty Dumpty no time
CBL see running in a limited time so
things were working on our retaining the
mpeg-2 because as of now then big do is
very large we transcribe dog and toss it
out because you know we've only got six
hard drives not 60 I we have a bit to go
on usability playing in the browser for
instance Mac Firefox is like the movie
man for us right now come November like
I said native support should be in there
and with so many senators and a couple
Congress people that the president
should give us enough time to really
expose that so I'll break for questions
if well here I can show you the saxby
chambliss thing so here's some data
coming from Center for Responsive
Politics about the speaker you can see
is his profile there you can see sector
totals agribusiness and finance are
right on top makes it a much more
interesting way to watch this footage
they're not always so direct but there's
often a connection